[Music]
if the marvel cinematic universe has a
center it's probably new york which is
where i live
so when my boss a day said i had to go
to every mcu filming location in the
city for a video
i said okay because i don't really have
a choice
so let's go
so at the end of captain america one we
watch him break out of hibernation to
learn that 70 years have passed and he's
in the 21st century
he learns this in times square we
thought it best to break it to you
slowly
slowly this former red light district is
now the biggest
loudest most overwhelming tourist trap
in the world blinding lights
overpriced food unhinged mascots packed
crowds
sex shops if i recap and i saw this i
would have gone back into a coma
honestly i can't think of a worse
location on the planet
to ease that man into the 21st century
maybe the international space station
also shield your secret government
organization and you're located in
times square why
here we are at washington square park if
you've ever seen avengers infinity war
this is where iron man and spider-man
fight that big dude who works for thanos
it's appropriate that this is the scene
of a battle since this actual park
stands above an estimated 20
000 corpses yeah the city of new york
purchased this land from a farm in the
1700s
as a place to bury criminals the poor
plagued victims and the unidentified
today it serves as the unofficial quad
of nyu on a typical day it's filled with
students
artists music skateboarding chess
and families few of whom realize what
lies beneath them
next we're gonna head down to 177a
bleaker street where in this scene thor
visits the home of dr strange
aka the sanctum sanctorum so here we are
and that behind me is 177 bleaker street
probably not what you expected
if you saw end game you may have noticed
that tony stark seems fixated on the
fact that doctor strange lives on
bleecker street
he mentions it here he went my face with
the planet while the bleaker street
magician gave away the store
and he mentioned it again here nice
place in the village though yeah on
sullivan street
why probably because tony's a
billionaire and billionaires love
thinking about investment returns
according to the tax history for this
building the market value for this
property in 2004 was 900 thousand
dollars
in 2020 the market value was 4.8 million
that alone would be an over 5x return
looking more closely at the apartment
that doesn't seem to be any nod to the
sanctum sanctorum
with the exception of this thing which
feels oddly out of place with the rest
of the building
i don't know what it is or why it's here
but i like it
speaking of new york real estate let's
head uptown to take a look at avengers
tower shown here to be standing over
grand central terminal
which means that tony stark must have
bought and destroyed the metlife
building
which as it stands today is estimated to
be worth 3 billion
it's hard to know if converting it to
avengers tower would increase or
decrease its value
on the one hand the renovations
technical improvements
self-sustaining power grid and celebrity
brand recognition could certainly add
value
on the other the fact that aliens and
robots keep showing up every few years
to destroy
it and everything around it could be
seen as a major liability
further north we find ourselves in
central park in bethesda terrace
this is where loki's teleported away
from earth at the end of the avengers
which would make this the exact spot
where loki and thor stood
a lot of people assume this is the
fountain from friends it's not
but it is the site of a duel and iron
fist which i don't know do we
is that do we care does that count is it
mcu
this statue above it is called the angel
of the waters and was designed by emma
stevens
first woman to be commissioned for a
major public art piece for the city in
1868
finally let's head to the queensborough
bridge where spider-man ditches a school
field trip to help the avengers fight
thanos
as you can see this bridge has not been
destroyed which is kind of a miracle
given its history
it was built in 1909 as a non-union job
which pissed off the quasi-terrorist
ring within the iron workers union
so they decided to blow it up with
dynamite just like they had to dozens of
other buildings across the country that
year
in the middle of laying down the
dynamite however they realized the
explosion would kill
30 men working in the powerhouse below
the bridge so they backed out
and thus the bridge still stands today
[Music]
you